Are we really about to head back to the wizarding
world of Harry Potter?
According to an anonymous report by We Got
This Covered, it could be a possibility.
The outlet, citing anonymous sources, claims
that the studio is developing a brand-new
Harry Potter movie featuring the three original
stars: Daniel Radcliffe, Emma Watson,and Rupert
Grint.
The purported project is an adaptation of
the stage play Harry Potter and the Cursed
Child, written by Jack Thorne from a story
he wrote with J.K.
Rowling and two-time Tony Award-winning theatre
director John Tiffany.
Given the stage play's success, it's not out
of the realm of reality that Warner Bros.
would want to make big bucks with a feature
film adaptation.
However, we can puncture quite a few holes
in this rumor.
For starters, this isn't the first time we've
heard reports that Warner Bros. wants to turn
Harry Potter and the Cursed Child into a film.
In August 2016, just two months after the
play began its London previews, New York Daily
News ran an article claiming that Warner Bros.
was interested in adapting the play for the
silver screen in a project that would debut
as soon as 2020.
The studio was said to have hoped that Radcliffe
would board the film to reprise his most famous
role.
This report started a hot fire of speculation
that began burning up social media.
In September 2016, Warner Bros. representatives
issued a statement debunking the rumor:
"Harry Potter and the Cursed Child is a stage
play, with no plans for there to be a film."
Additionally, there's the issue of whether
Radcliffe, Watson, and Grint would genuinely
want to come back to the franchise.
In a 2018 interview with The Guardian, Grint
said:
"It was nice to breathe the fresh air and
now I’m really enjoying stepping further
away from that blue-screen world."
That doesn't exactly inspire a lot of confidence
in the idea that Grint would be willing to
come back to the Harry Potter universe for
another movie.
For his part, Radcliffe has said that he's
not really interested in appearing again as
Harry Potter.
"Oh God I've still got these on.
I don't need these.
They're just for the character."
It also seems like he's done with the character
in more ways than one.
In November 2018, Radcliffe admitted that
he had no intention of ever watching Harry
Potter and the Cursed Child, since he would
feel like he was being monitored for his reaction.
"I feel like it would not be a relaxing evening
at the theater.
I feel like I would be being watched for my
reaction."
Those comments pose an important question:
If Radcliffe doesn't even want to see the
play, why would he want to be in a film adaptation
of it?
Unsurprisingly, Watson has taken a similar
stance as her Potter co-stars on the matter.
Asked during a SiriusXM interview if she would
ever return to the wizarding word, Watson
answered,
"Ask me in another 10 years."
Since Warner Bros. suffered disappointment
with the less-than-fantastic performance of
Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald,
it's possible that the studio is looking to
get its Potter-verse back on track by finally
going through with Harry Potter and the Cursed
Child.
It's also possible that the studio was willing
to spend whatever money it took to convince
Radcliffe, Grint, and Watson to join the film,
knowing that their involvement would boost
audience interest.
Though the three stars have done well for
themselves outside the Potter franchise, none
have reached the same level of success they
attained during their time as witches and
wizards.
With what might have been major money on the
table and the promise of even more success,
it's possible that Radcliffe, Grint, and Watson
really might accept an offer to star in Harry
Potter and the Cursed Child.
Still, there's nothing that's actually been
confirmed, and Cursed Child representatives
in New York reportedly declared on September
5,
"There are no plans whatsoever for a movie."
If anything comes out to make this rumor more
credible, rest assured that we'll fill you
in with all the details.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.